look here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I'm camping in really deep
snow in her blizzard
it's gonna be fun
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
all right I think I'm done digging
I'm exhausted
oh dry gloves
and what I need
all right there we go
let's get some water boiling I am so
hungry
oh it's getting cold
well guys now that I'm done digging let
me give you a tour of the shelter here
look at that
oh
it's a lot of digging
we got vaulted ceilings there well to
give you an idea how deep the snow is
this pole is nine feet tall that's three
meter and it doesn't quite reach the
roof so we're about 11 and a half 12
feet deep or about four meters the crazy
thing is I didn't even dig to the Bottom
now the tunnel I'm sleeping in tonight
goes about six and a half feet into the
side of the Hill
and then this part is about seven and a
half feet long originally I was just
gonna dig the tunnel this way but I
ended up hitting something solid
couldn't go any deeper so I ended up
having to hang it right so my rough
estimate is I ended up digging out about
400 cubic feet of snow so
yeah moved a lot of snow today
I didn't bring any Fancy Pants camping
meals tonight I've got a leftover MRE
packet I think this is Asian style beef
strips We're Gonna warm that up in our
water here once that's warmed up I'm
gonna make some of this uh chicken and
rice here never tried this flavor before
we'll see if it's any good
all right I'm gonna make a cup of warm
tea while I wait for my dinner to
hydrate I'm freezing
hahaha
oh that's good
I am so thirsty and so cold this tastes
amazing oh
flavor but it tastes so good right now
it's gonna mix up the MRE with this so
you can see if it tastes a little better
these dehydrated camping meals are
really nice after a hard day like today
but I have a hard time eating them more
than a couple days in a row
that's it all right this is how I do the
dishes
for dessert I've got one of these shelf
life apple turnovers this thing will
last like 20 years before it goes bad or
something like that I'm gonna heat it up
by putting it on top of the pot like
that
all right we're gonna give this a try a
couple year old apple turnover let's see
if it's any good
you know it's kind of dry
maybe I'm just hungry but this thing
tastes pretty good
all right I brought along the second
dessert it's a chocolate covered
macadamia nut with caramel but it's
frozen so I got a thaw it out
[Music]
oh that's good
oh that tasted wonderful
pulled out my water bottle with boy
boiling water I'm gonna throw it in my
bag to keep me warm tonight but in the
meantime
I'm putting in my jacket
[Music]
hey guys check out my snow shovel this
thing took a beating today the bottom
two feet of the snow was almost ice
Black Diamond makes this shovel and I've
had it for about four or five years and
I have used and abused this shovel but I
think it might be time to retire it and
get a new one I'll definitely be buying
another one this is a good shovel it is
so quiet here under the snow but every
once in a while I'm hearing this noise
at first I thought it was an animal but
I think the wind is kicking up
let's see
oh yeah
we got a good 15 20 mile per hour wind
ripping through the mountains here check
it out the winds blowing a snow drift
over my snowshoes I better put those
away before I lose them
you can't tell the wind's blowing at all
when you get down here in the shelter
and since the wind is coming down from
the mountains from that direction that
Arch is keeping the wind from swirling
down here into the trench that's the big
advantage of these snow shelters they
keep you out of the wind but you got to
build them correctly that's why you
never want the entrance to your snow
cave and the entrance to your shelter
pointing in the same direction you never
want to give the wind a straight shot
into your sleeping area the other
advantage of these snow caves is that if
you build them right they're always
about 15 to 20 degrees Fahrenheit now
that's not warm but if it's zero degrees
out or negative 20 it's a big deal
another trick is you want to make sure
the bed is always at least 12 inches
above the floor of the trench sometimes
the cold air will kind of collect in the
bottom of the trench and you don't want
your sleeping bag to be the lowest point
in the shelter now that I'm not moving
around and shoveling snow I'm getting
really cold I'm gonna hop in that
sleeping back
go ahead and put on my down booties
these things are so great for keeping
your feet warm Western mountaineering
makes these
all right got my clown shoes on and my
stretchy pants
let's see if I can get into my bag
without getting myself all snowy
makes a big difference if you make your
shelter big enough so that you don't
have to crawl on your hands and knees
all right oh that hot water bottle feels
so good with these snow caves you always
got to make them wide enough and tall
enough that you can roll around a little
bit and never touch the snow if even a
small part of you rubs up against the
snow in the night it's going to be so
cold don't want any part of that well it
gets dark really early up here in Alaska
so I got a little bit of time before I
need to go to sleep I think I'm gonna
listen to an audiobook all right guys
it's late I'm gonna turn off the camera
and I'm gonna see you guys in the
morning and I'm gonna sleep in it's been
a long day
oh good morning I was sitting in my bag
for way too long
it's nice and toasty in here guys that
Windstorm that started last night got a
lot worse but it is so cozy in here you
can't hear or feel any wind at all
I mean listen
you can't hear anything you know it's
not exactly warm in here but without the
wind it's a really manageable
temperature
all right enough talking I gotta go use
the bathroom bad
oh
look at that we got some serious snow in
the shelter
oh
my gloves are so Frozen
I'm solid
my stove is under here
there's like six eight inches of snow in
the bottom of my shelter
oh my goodness
oh
it is
look at that the wall is completely
buried
it's got to be gusting 50 miles per hour
out here it's hard to stand up
you can barely see my stairs
oh
look at this
well looks like I got some digging to do
if I want to make breakfast
there's so much snow being blown into
the trench I don't think I can get the
stove lit out here so I'm gonna go ahead
and cook inside here
foreign
scramble cheese and eggs and potatoes
and stuff
well I brought my Tin Can fireplace with
me but I didn't light it last night
because I was so tired but I could
really use something to warm my gloves
up right now so I'm gonna go ahead and
light it up because there's not a lot of
firewood around I brought a chunk of one
of those fireplace logs you buy at the
supermarket
[Music]
there we go
a little chunk like that will only last
a couple hours but it makes a really
nice cozy little fire works good for
drying out gloves we're gonna try my
bandito scramble
that is not appetizing
adding too much water didn't help it I'm
going to eat some trail mix so my mouth
will stop being angry at me
well my stuff is quickly getting buried
in snow I need to straighten up before I
start losing equipment
oh
my God
[Music]
I'm all packed up but I think I better
get out of here this storm's only
getting worse and the snow's getting
deeper and my fingers are so cold yeah
this is a good shelter but it is quickly
filling up with snow probably got five
feet of snow is accumulated in the foot
of the trench since I got up this
morning you see that it's time to go
home
all right let's go see if we can find my
snowshoes
which way do I go
if I get into trees I could get a block
from the wind
my fingers are so cold I can't get my
car keys out of my pocket I gotta warm
them up in my armpits for a little bit
it's a little blustery out there but
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video if
you want to see more videos from the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning all right
guys I'll see you next Saturday if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]